se cumplen las peores predicciones para
brasil por primera vez el país supera
los 3.000 muertos de comida en 24 horas
son exactamente 3.251 según datos del
conace el consejo nacional de
secretarios de salud hay que recordar
que los martes las cifras siempre son
más altas porque durante el fin de
semana hay un retraso en la recopilación
de los datos aún así se cumplen las
previsiones de los epidemiólogos que
ahora incluso hablan de otro récord
brasil en las próximas semanas podría
alcanzar los 4000 o incluso los 5.000
muertos diarios conocemos esta noticia
el mismo día en que por fin el nuevo
ministro de salud marcelo quiroga asume
su cargo una semana después de haber
sido nombrado y es que durante una
semana brasil tuvo dos ministros de
sanidad el que sale eduardo para suelo y
el nuevo que eroga la razón según los
analistas es que bolsonaro el presidente
de brasil mantuvo hasta este momento a
para suelo para garantizarle una
inmunidad política a la espera de crear
un cargo a medida la razón
el tribunal supremo está investigando
para suelo por su responsabilidad en la
crisis del oxígeno en manaos recordamos
que en enero se acabó el oxígeno de los
hospitales decenas de pacientes murieron
centenares de pacientes tuvieron que ser
trasladados a hospitales de otros
estados la empresa proveedora asegura
que avisó al ministerio de salud que se
estaba acabando el oxígeno y que podría
haber un colapso y el supremo
precisamente está investigando porque
para suelo desoyó esta información y por
qué no hizo algo para minimizar el
impacto